kind of prefer Marvel movies we are
Marvel yeah but you're you know marvel
licensed by Fox it's like if the Beatles
were produced by Nickelback it's music
but it sucks by the end of Deadpool 3
Deadpool will become the leader of a new
Avengers team if you've been hearing all
of the recent Deadpool 3 news and you've
been thinking wow Deadpool 3 sounds like
it's going to be insane well it is but
let's talk about what exactly is going
to go down to make Deadpool get into the
m you and then become a leader of a
giant Avengers team this morning The
Insider cryptic HD quality who has a
great track record teased the TVA in
Deadpool 3 simply tweeting knock knock
and then a gif of the TVA for all time
always now we've known that the TVA is
going to be in Deadpool 3 for some time
now in fact we know about a character
Paradox who is going to be working for
the TVA who is reportedly going to be
played by Matthew mcfan but the question
is is the TVA hunting dead pulled down
we have to talk about this think about
this for a second does this make
complete sense after we saw Loki season
2 as far as we know the TVA really isn't
hunting people down anymore they've
dramatically shift their focus after
Loki essentially created the Multiverse
well maybe he didn't create it but at
the very least he allows it to exist now
Branch timelines happened before and the
Multiverse was real except the TVA did
not allow the Multiverse to essentially
come into existence but now that Loki's
in charge the Multiverse lives so as far
far as the TVA is concerned we saw at
the end of Loki season 2 that their
primary job now is to locate Kang
variants and take care of them they're
really just focused on keeping the
Multiverse safe and allowing it to exist
sure they might capture some people who
are going around the Multiverse doing
harm causing incursions but we know
they're not really pruning people
anymore that was kind of a big part of
Loki season 2 and that's really
important because that's going to come
into play for Deadpool 3 big time and
based off of what we know I don't really
think the TVA is going to be hunting
Deadpool down and Wolverine down the
entire film as they go on this
multiversal journey I know Deadpool will
be with the TVA but I don't think
they'll be fighting each other I think
Deadpool is going to be helping the TVA
for a very specific reason and this
reason comes from the recent plot
synopsis that we have for Deadpool 3
some of you might have heard it by now
but it reads after facing some
professional setbacks while going
through a midlife crisis Wade Wilson
decides to officially retire Deadpool
and becomes a used car salesman but when
his friends family and the whole world
are at stake Deadpool decides to bring
his katanas out of retirement he
recruits an unwilling and wary Wolverine
to not only fight for their survival But
ultimately their legacy if this plot
synopsis ends up being true which it
might be because the reason he could
retire is because he went back in time
and saved Vanessa and changed a few
things in his favor and maybe he just
wants to have a really nice married
quiet life now have a kid be a parent
work a job at the used car sales lot be
kind of normal this could sound kind of
perfect to him based off of the life
that he's already had but what happens
when his world and the Multiverse are in
Jeopardy well of course he would want to
save his world his life the people that
he loves so Deadpool's universe is dying
and to save it he finds Wolverine and
travels the Multiverse this is the start
of Deadpool becoming the leader of the
new Avengers team and yes Deadpool did
time travel and change a lot of things
at the end of Deadpool 2o but remember
the TVA isn't exactly pruning people any
anymore for creating Branch timelines
their main focus right now is Kang who
Deadpool should ultimately realize he
needs to focus on as well however he's
not going to realize this until the end
of the film why well because we know
that Deadpool is going to travel the
Multiverse he's going to find a bunch of
different Wolverine variants he's going
to run into some X-Men and ultimately
Kang the Conqueror as far as we know is
not the villain of this movie but the
TVA will definitely realize what
Deadpool has done however I believe that
they will try to recruit Deadpool into
helping them and they could be
specifically trying to recruit him
because of Wolverine According to some
plot details about Deadpool 3 posted by
The Insider my time to shine hello a few
months ago the character Mr Paradox who
is going to be a TVA agent who is kind
of going to take the place of Mobius at
least just for this movie is trying to
recruit Wolverine the reason is of
course this film takes place after the
events of Loki season 2 so essentially
we have a new TVA here and according to
the details the TVA gets word that the
kangs Kang and all of his variants are
all Gathering and a new multiversal war
is about to start and we've seen this
already this was literally the
post-credit scene for Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania the Council of Kings
have gathered all of the other king
variants and they are literally about to
explain hey we have to control
everything we have to go to war we have
to kill the Avengers all the heroes
Fantastic 4 X-Men everybody or
eventually they will defeat us so what
does the TVA do well they start to
create an army of multiversal Heroes
we've talked about this a lot it sounds
like they're going to create these
Heroes and gather them from Worlds that
are dying well if you go back to the
Deadpool 3 synopsis it sounds like
Deadpool's world the fox universe is
dying it's one of those dying worlds so
Deadpool and the TVA actually have a
common goal they want to stop the
destruction of universes and Deadpool
wants to stop the destruction of his own
universe so they work together I imagine
it will kind of be what the TVA
specifically MO did with Loki they
captured Loki they were going to prune
him he was literally in court about to
be pruned but Mobius stepped in and
saved him I'm assuming this might be
kind of the same thing that Deadpool
might share somewhat of the same fate
Deadpool gets on the tva's radar because
of course the time travel at the end of
Deadpool 2 but also in other universes
Deadpool is really good friends with
Wolverine so if the TVA is trying to
recruit Wolverine maybe they recruit
Deadpool to try and help with that just
to clarify we're unsure of really how
Wolverine and dead pool come together in
the film there's been rumors that
Deadpool gets captured there's been
rumors that Wolverine gets captured and
they break out and they travel the
Multiverse together but that's actually
not completely relevant to how Deadpool
becomes the leader of the new Avengers
it's important but not for the specific
ending that Deadpool has we know that
they come together and at the end after
traveling the Multiverse and dealing
with whoever they're going to deal with
whoever the villain is of Deadpool 3 or
villains they're ultimately going to
come to the conclusion that they realize
Kang and the millions of King variants
are trying to take over the Multiverse
and this is the reason that the
Multiverse is falling apart this is the
reason that Deadpool's home his world
everybody he loves is at Jeopardy right
now and could die So eventually Deadpool
realizes that they need to defeat Kang
and his millions of variants who are
trying to take over the universe so it's
up to him and his buddy Wolverine who
are working with the TVA and what is the
TVA trying to do well they're trying to
put together a big multiversal hero team
and since Deadpool in Deadpool 3 is
literally going to travel throughout the
Universe seeing multiple different teams
X-Men Fantastic 4 Avengers as far as we
know well who better to lead the team
well in all honesty they're probably
other people who are better and less
sarcastic but in this situation Deadpool
and Wolverine are going to have the most
experience because they are going to be
true Multiverse Travelers Doctor Strange
at this point in time and Wanda are the
only two Avengers who have really
Multiverse traveled and Wanda did that
via dreamwalking but besides them nobody
else has really Multiverse traveled the
old X-Men universes didn't do that they
kind of time traveled but no Multiverse
travel the Fantastic 4 did not do that
and again The Avengers really haven't
done that as well with the exception of
a few who reportedly aren't going to be
a part of the new Avengers film so
really it all points to Deadpool and
Wolverine being the leaders of this huge
multiversal team and we've heard that
Toby Maguire Spider-Man is also going to
be another one of these leaders which
would totally make sense because like
I've said before I can totally see
Deadpool going oh we need to recruit
another Marvel Legacy character let's go
visit Toby the original onscreen
Spider-Man not that new Tom Holland guy
I could totally see Deadpool cracking a
joke about this so ultimately Deadpool
ends up becoming the leader of the new
Avengers team alongside Wolverine and
hopefully fingers crossed Toby Maguire
I'm personally really excited that
there's a lot of mystery still
surrounding Deadpool 3 and not
everything is leaked but knowing
Deadpool is going to play a huge role
after Deadpool 3 as well in the
multiversal war is really awesome and a
few insiders have confirmed this as well
Deadpool is going to continue to be a
lead alongside Wolverine even after
Deadpool 3 so not only is Deadpool 3
already super exciting but after
Deadpool 3 is going to be equally
exciting as Deadpool and Wolverine are
sticking around in the MCU so let me
know how excited you are about this in
the comments down below let me know your
own theories if you have them please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
the MCU and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're automatically entered in
our giveaway for a chance to win a PS5
an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items and some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof